[MUSIC PLAYING]
You don't become good
because you think you're good.
ANNOUNCER: Wayne
Gretzky, "the Great One",
has become the
greatest of them all!
You become good because you're
committed to becoming better
each and every day.
I wasn't the biggest
player in the NHL,
and I didn't have
the hardest shot.
But what I had was a
will to want to score.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If I got one goal, I wanted two.
If I had two, I wanted three.
It never stopped.
Through this
MasterClass, you're going
to learn you have to
have a belief in what you
want to accomplish.
You don't have to be an athlete
to make an athlete's mindset
work for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNOUNCER: Unbelievable!
Wayne Gretzky, the
greatest scorer ever
in the history of the NHL!
If you have a love and
a passion for something,
the rewards are endless.
[CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is MasterClass.